moving without the rocks draymond green
does his job setting the screen
you have to have help
and like i said
looking for the ring
number four
here in game
six curry cuts it fakes fires
three-pointer bang
steph curry from downtown a 15-point
lead as smartish the celtic faithful now
heading for the exits
with 130 remaining steph curry gets open
wide open from the side out of bounds al
often fly by
sigh relief in the building realizing
that
chef curry with the shot has just put
you to sleep comes a point in time when
you got to send the kids upstairs it's
grown folks time
spectacular performance 12 points 12
rebounds eight assists
goes bob myers
of course steph curry with his dad the
emotions just pouring out
it might be his fourth but it means so
much
all the sacrifice all the work
[Applause]
warriors are ready to celebrate
and that'll do it it's over the golden
state warriors return to a familiar
place they're on top of the nba world
the fourth title in eight years